Hallo allerseits, herzlich willkommen bei
unserem neuen Easy German Live-Format.
Wie ihr seht, sitze ich gemütlich zu Hause,
aber Cari und Janusz sind für uns unterwegs.
Bevor ich sie hier in unseren Stream hole,
ein paar Hinweise.
Hinweis Nummer eins: Schreibt doch mal in
den Chat, wenn ihr gerade live zuschaut, von
wo ihr uns zuschaut.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, wo ihr in der Welt
gerade seid.
Nummer zwei: Ihr werdet morgen oder später
schon Untertitel finden unter diesem Video,
jetzt noch nicht, denn wir sind gerade live.
Und das waren schon die Hinweise und ich würde
sagen, wir holen mal Cari und Janusz ins Bild
und schauen, wo sie gerade stecken.
Hallo!
Hallo ihr beiden.
- Manuel, hörst du uns?
- Ja.
Ich höre euch.
Wir sind...
- Wo steckt ihr?
Wir sind gerade an einem Ort, kannst du schon
raten, wo wir sind?
Ich weiß nicht genau, was man hier sieht.
Es sieht weihnachtlich und ein bisschen grau
und kommerziell aus.
Oh ja, das ist der Alexanderplatz in Berlin.
Hallo Janusz!
Hi!
Und hi an alle auch.
Wie geht es dir heute, Janusz?
Oh, voll gut.
Frisch.
Manuel, wie geht es dir?
Mir geht es auch sehr gut, ich bin auch frisch
und gut drauf.
Ja, Manuel, wir sind heute zum Alexanderplatz
gefahren.
Das ist ein ganz zentraler Ort in Berlin und
hier gibt es einen Weihnachtsmarkt.
Ich muss ehrlich zugeben, das ist nicht unser
Lieblingsort hier, denn wie du schon sagst,
der Alexanderplatz ist ein bisschen grau,
nicht nur wegen des Wetters heute.
Hallo!
Wollt ihr einmal Hallo sagen?
Wir sind gerade live bei YouTube.
Ja, ich weiß, Cari, ich hab' gerade die Benachrichtigung
bekommen.
Oh ja?
Du hast eine Benachrichtigung bekommen?
Und dann hat mein Mann gesagt: "Guck mal,
hier stehen sie."
Perfekt!
Ja.
Woher kommst du?
Aus Polen.
Aus Polen, dzień dobry!
Dzień dobry!
Und...
Wir sind gerade bei unseren Großeltern zu
Besuch.
Das ist ja schön.
Und jetzt besucht ihr den Weihnachtsmarkt
in Berlin?
Genau.
Alle Weihnachtsmärkte.
Alle?
- Wir fahren gerade, ich denke in den Lucia
Weihnachtsmarkt.
Und wie findest du diesen Weihnachtsmarkt?
Ja, ich mag ihn, wie alle hier in Berlin,
weil hier ist die Atmosphäre besonders, so,
super weihnachtlich und ja, perfekt.
Das ist schön.
Und jetzt fahrt ihr zum Lucia Weihnachtsmarkt?
Ja, ja.
Das ist einer der schönsten Weihnachtsmärkte
in Berlin, der ist aber auch am vollsten,
deswegen sind wir da heute nicht hingegangen,
aber viel Spaß dort.
Ja, danke, vielen Dank!
Wie heißt du?
Sonja.
Sonja, habt einen schönen Tag!
Danke, tschüss!
Ciao!
Wie schön.
- Guck, so schnell trifft man hier Leute,
Manuel.
Ja, das ist wirklich schön.
Außer Sonja schauen uns gerade Leute aus
Argentinien zu, hallo Octavio, aus Spanien,
hallo Paco.
Ich zeig' mal hier ein paar Einblendungen.
Das ist Paco, dann ist Mischa aus Irland dabei,
aus Peru ist Gonzalo dabei und ja, ganz schön
viele Leute schauen live zu.
Das ist wirklich fantastisch.
Und Facebook-Zuschauer haben wir auch noch,
Libby aus der Schweiz.
Komm, wir gehen mal weiter.
Jane aus Michigan.
Also es scrollt hier so schnell vorbei, dass
ich gar nicht mehr so schnell klicken kann.
Sehr schön, dass ihr alle dabei seid.
Ja, wir gehen jetzt ein bisschen weiter über
den Weihnachtsmarkt, Manuel.
Was kann man machen auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt,
Janusz?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Geschenke kaufen, hübsche Warenstände bewundern.
Essen, man kann sehr viel essen und trinken.
Man kann essen, trinken, man kann (mit) eine(m)
Karussell fahren.
Hier zum Beispiel, da kann man Spaß haben,
wenn man ein Kind ist.
Aber grundsätzlich wird es von einem Christen
erwartet, dass er sich volllaufen lässt und
einfach (eine) gute Zeit verbringt hier.
Dieses Wort müssen wir erklären, volllaufen
lassen, Janusz.
Das ist eine sehr praktische Vokabel.
Das heißt, dass man sehr viel Alkohol trinkt.
Janusz, was möchtest du denn jetzt gerne
trinken?
Einen Kaffee oder einen Glühwein?
Keinen Glühwein, ich mag Glühwein nicht,
aber ich hoffe, dass ich hier diesen Hot Mojo,
Mojito… - Mojito?
…ja, trinke.
Und den trinke ich allerdings ohne den Schuss,
also ohne den Alkohol.
Aber Mojito ist immer Alkohol, das ist ein
Cocktail.
Nicht bei mir.
Okay, Janusz möchte gerne einen heißen Mojito
ohne Alkohol trinken.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher…
Bitte Gin ohne Alkohol. - …ob es das hier
gibt.
Manuel, was willst du denn gerne, dass wir
das jetzt machen?
Wir können jetzt einige Sachen hier ausprobieren.
Genau, ich würde mal sagen: Holt euch mal
was zu trinken und während ihr euch etwas
zu trinken holt, könnt ihr, liebe Zuschauer*innen,
uns eine Frage schreiben in die Kommentare.
Ich schaue grad, wenn ihr immer seht, dass
ich hier so ein bisschen in die Seite schaue,
dann schaue ich auf eure Chat-Kommentare und
da könnt ihr gerne Fragen stellen.
Oder wenn ihr möchtet, dass Cari und Janusz
etwas Besonderes ausprobieren oder machen
oder sich anschauen, dann könnt ihr auch
eine kleine Mission in den Chat schreiben,
und ja.
Ja.
Ich würde sagen…
Janusz, Manuel sagt, wir sollen uns was zu
trinken holen, während wir auf die Fragen
von den Zuschauern warten.
Wollen wir das machen?
Ja, gerne, ja.
Okay.
Und was ist denn das bekannteste Getränk,
was man normalerweise auf dem Glühwein…
auf dem, jetzt habe ich es schon gesagt, auf
dem Weihnachtsmarkt trinkt?
Warte mal kurz, Manuel, ich würde sagen…
Janusz, hol du uns doch mal was zu trinken,
ja?
Für mich zum Beispiel einen Glühwein, aber
lieber noch einen Apfelpunsch, wenn es das
gibt.
Ja, Apfelpunsch will ich auch haben, ja.
Okay, da ist eine Hütte und dann treffen
wir uns hier gleich wieder.
Kameramann auch?
Nee, ne?
Du hast…
Doch der… Lorenz kann auch was trinken,
Janusz.
So, Cari, du hast dir jetzt schon einen Glühwein
bestellt, das ist ja so das bekannteste Getränk.
Kannst du das kurz beschreiben?
Und dann habe ich eine Frage für dich.
Also man trinkt traditionell… Lass uns ein
bisschen weiter hier rüberkommen, weil es
ist sehr laut hier an der, am Glühweinstand.
Man trinkt traditionell Glühwein auf dem
Weihnachtsmarkt.
Das ist eigentlich roter Wein, der warm gemacht
wird, mit Gewürzen.
Und ich persönlich bin kein Glühwein-Fan.
Lorenz, bist du ein Glühwein-Fan?
Ja, manchmal, wenn der gut gemacht ist, auf
jeden Fall.
Also, wenn er gut gemacht ist, trinkt Lorenz,
der ist heute hinter der Kamera.
Soll ich dich mal vorstellen, Lorenz?
Hier ist Lorenz.
Hallo.
Da… oh!
Da ist Ja… Lorenz hinter der Kamera.
Ja, ansonsten gibt es auch andere Getränke.
Es gibt zum Beispiel Apfelpunsch, das hätte
ich gerne.
Das ist eigentlich heißer Apfelsaft, auch
mit Gewürzen und manchmal auch mit Alkohol.
Okay.
Apropos Essen:
Ja.
Haikm fragt: "Was kochst du, Cari, zu Weihnachten
dieses Jahr?"
Oh, ich koche gar nichts zu Weihnachten, das
macht meine Mutter.
Oh, das ist ja ein Luxus.
- Ich kann doch gar nicht kochen, Manuel.
Und was wird deine Mutter kochen dieses Jahr?
Weißt du das schon?
Ehrlich gesagt weiß ich das noch nicht.
Wir diskutieren jede(s) Weihnachten und oft
machen wir Raclette.
Das ist ein französisches… oder ich bin
mir nicht sicher.
Kommt Raclette aus der Schweiz?
Ich glaube, es kommt aus der Schweiz, ja.
Raclette, ja.
Das ist also eine Tradition in der Schweiz,
die man auch in Deutschland gerne macht.
Man hat dort so kleine Pfannen und kann dort
Gemüse, Fleisch reinlegen und mit Käse überbacken,
und ein sehr interaktives Gericht.
Das stimmt.
So, dann fragt John: "Welchen Weihnachtsmarkt
könnt ihr empfehlen in Berlin?"
Ist der Weihnachtsmarkt auf dem Alexanderplatz
empfehlenswert?
Also der Alexanderplatz-Weihnachtsmarkt ist,
finde ich, nicht so empfehlenswert.
Wir sind hier hingegangen, weil es der Alexanderplatz
ist.
Das ist ein bekannter Platz, es ist aber immer
sehr touristisch hier.
Und es ist jetzt gerade sehr leer, was gut
für uns ist, weil wir wollten nicht in so
eine enge Menge gehen.
Den Weihnachtsmarkt, den ich am meisten empfehlen
kann, ist der Sankt Lucia Weihnachtsmarkt,
der ist in der Kulturbrauerei.
Dort ist es sehr skandinavisch, es gibt viele
Händler aus verschiedenen skandinavischen
Ländern.
Oh, da ist Janusz mit Getränken.
Hallo Janusz!
Du hast ja was Leckeres mitgebracht.
Was ist das?
Das ist Apfelpunsch.
Lecker!
Und jetzt können wir die Maske abnehmen,
weil wir konsumieren.
Manuel, es gibt eine Maskenpflicht auf dem
Weihnachtsmarkt, und wie du siehst, hängt
meine Maske jetzt hier.
Und man muss Masken tragen, es sei denn, man
trinkt etwas.
Was für eine Bevorzugung der Säufer schon
wieder.
Ja.
So, und Janusz, was hast du dir gekauft?
- Ja, Prost!
Genau das, was ihr, aber ohne Alkohol.
Prost!
Super lecker, ja.
- Super.
Ja, Manuel.
Wie schön.
Der Livestream… Erzähl du mal weiter und
wir machen eine kurze Pause.
Ja, trinkt mal euren Apfelpunsch und währenddessen
können wir mal kurz auf ein Bild von oben
schauen, wie das hier aussieht.
Also, das ist jetzt kein Bild aus dem Winter,
das ist im Sommer gemacht, aber das ist der
Alexanderplatz, auf dem ihr jetzt gerade steht.
Und dieser Platz ist also mitten in Berlin,
gehört noch zu Berlin-Mitte und hat auch
eine längere Geschichte.
Wir können später mal noch Bilder zeigen,
wie es da früher aussah.
Und ganz in der Nähe vom Alexanderplatz ist
der Fernsehturm und das ist der höchste,
das höchste Gebäude in Deutschland.
Cari, wie ist es?
Wollt ihr gleich noch den Fernsehturm uns
zeigen?
…meine Maske mit dem Kabel auseinander gefummelt
und jetzt höre ich dich wieder.
Wir wollen euch gleich den Fernsehturm zeigen,
ja.
Er ist jetzt hinter einem Gebäude verschwunden,
aber wir werden jetzt hier auftrinken und
dann werden wir den Weihnachtsmarkt verlassen
und euch ein bisschen mehr vom Alexanderplatz
zeigen.
Grundsätzlich ist der Alexanderplatz eine
sehr große Fläche, hast du vielleicht gerade
gezeigt auf der Karte, und saisonal wird hier
immer irgendwas gemacht.
Also Weihnachten ist hier der Weihnachtsmarkt,
es gibt aber auch verschiedene andere Märkte,
die im Jahr hier sind.
Ich glaube, es gibt auch zu Ostern etwas,
es gibt immer zu den verschiedenen Feiertagen…
gibt es hier was, denn, ja, es ist ein sehr
zentraler Platz, viele Menschen kommen hierher.
Und das ist ja auch ein historisch besonderer
Platz.
Früher war das hier das Zentrum von Ost-Berlin
und ja, hier sind immer noch sehr viele Geschäfte
und viel ist hier los.
Und du hast gerade schon gesagt, der Al…
Ist ja leer.
…der Alexanderplatz ist sehr touristisch,
ne?
Ich glaube, das ist ein Ort, wo man als Tourist
schnell hinkommt, weil es mitten in Berlin
ist und so groß und bekannt, aber als Berliner
ist man da eigentlich sehr selten, oder?
Ungerne ist man dort.
Das ist ein schönes Wort, was gut dazu passt.
Man ist also nicht gerne auf dem Alexanderplatz,
auch in der U-Bahn-Station nicht so gerne.
Es ist einfach so ein Umstiegspunkt, ein Platz,
wo sehr viele Menschen zusammenkommen.
Und der Alexanderplatz selber, der ist sehr…
ja, wie kann man die Architektur beschreiben,
Manuel?
Sehr grau, sehr… so eine klassische sozialistische
Architektur ist das eigentlich.
Es ist manchmal sehr schön, aber es ist auch
sehr viel Abstand, und dadurch, dass hier
sehr viele Touristen sind, kommen die meisten
Berliner eher ungern hierhin, würde ich sagen.
Richtig.
Ja, es gibt auch schon einen Kommentar von
Marc, der sagt: "Besucht die Weltzeituhr,
bitte."
Das weiß ich nicht, ob wir das jetzt schaffen,
aber auf dem Alexanderplatz gibt es eine Weltzeituhr.
Das ist… ja, vielleicht könnt ihr das gleich
kurz zeigen, aber es ist ein…
Wir können mal darüber zeigen, man sieht
die allerdings von hier nicht, aber so seht
ihr ungefähr, wie es hier aussieht.
Hinten gibt es so ein großes, ja, wie nennt
man denn das, diesen Turm dort?
Tja.
Das ist ein Brunnen, glaube ich, oder?
Das ist doch ein…
Nee, das ist so ein Ding, was man auch Weihnachten
bastelt.
Ja, siehst du, wir kennen die eigenen Traditionen
nicht.
Lorenz, weißt du, wie das heißt?
Nee, leider nicht.
Okay.
Vorne links sehen wir Janusz, er guckt sich
gerade an einem Stand für Brieftaschen um.
Und wie ihr seht, ist hier noch nicht so viel
los, wahrscheinlich wird sich das später
ändern, nämlich so… Vielleicht in ein,
zwei Stunden ist hier etwas mehr los, wenn
vielleicht ein paar Besucher hier sind.
Wenn die Leute nicht mehr arbeiten, dann kommen
sie hierhin und treffen sich zum Glühweintrinken.
Ja.
Ja, wie ist das denn?
Dürft ihr das Getränk jetzt mitnehmen und
euch schon auf den Weg machen oder möchtet
ihr ein paar…
Das ist das Problem.
Ich würde gerne gehen, aber ich muss noch
trinken.
Janusz, kannst du mir helfen?
Beim Trinken?
Ja.
Nein, ich will keinen Alkohol.
Okay.
Ja, ich habe das Gefühl, es geht gar nicht
leer, Manuel.
Ich trinke noch die Hälfte und dann gehen
wir.
Okay, dann stelle ich euch noch ein paar Fragen.
Und zwar…
Unterwegs können wir so ein paar Sachen zum
Essen zeigen.
Es gibt jetzt Fragen, komm mal her, Janusz.
Es gibt schon die erste Challenge von Nagaha,
und zwar möchte sie gerne, dass ihr ein oder
zwei Weihnachtslieder vorsingt.
Oh, wir sollen Weihnachtslieder singen.
Janusz, kannst du singen?
Leider nicht.
Und auch keine Weihnachtslieder.
Okay, eins schaffen wir.
Leise rieselt der Schnee.
Oh, das schaffen wir.
Leise rieselt der Schnee, still und starr
liegt der See.
Oh, jetzt habe ich schon vergessen.
Weißt du weiter, Lorenz?
Nee, leider auch überhaupt nicht.
Weihnachtlich.
Okay, dann "O Tannenbaum".
O Tannenbaum, o Tannenbaum, wie grün sind
deine Blätter.
Du grünst nicht nur zur Weihnachtszeit, nein
auch im Sommer, wenn es schneit.
Guck mal, ich kenne den Text überhaupt nicht,
Manuel.
O Tannenbaum, o Tannenbaum, wie grün sind
deine Blätter.
- Okay, ich weiß wieder.
Du grünst nicht nur zur Sommerzeit, nein
auch im Winter, wenn es schneit.
Wieso grünst der?
Der Weihnachtsbaum, der Tannenbaum ist doch
grün.
Der ist das ganze Jahr über grün, deswegen
grünt er.
- Der Witz war vom Grunzen.
Man sagt doch grunzen, oder?
- Nicht grunzen, grün… grünen ist das
Verb.
Das hat nichts mit grunzen zu tun.
Der ist grün.
Das war der Witz eben halt.
Ja, Manuel.
Okay.
Was sagst du heute zu unserem Besuch auf dem
Weihnachtsmarkt?
Ja, es gibt noch ein paar Fragen zum…
Aber hier gibt es interessante… Guck mal,
statt Papier zu verschwenden, geben sie dir
die Currywurst in so gebackenen…
Okay.
Janusz, es gibt einige Fragen, die beantworten
wir jetzt.
- Es gibt noch ein paar Fragen zum Weihnachtsmarkt.
Erst mal sagt Meax…
Zur Stelle.
Das, worüber wir gerade gesprochen haben,
könnte eine Weihnachtspyramide sein.
Das könnte durchaus sein.
Ja, das könnte sein.
Es gibt ein paar Fragen dazu, was es auf dem
Weihnachtsmarkt außer Essen und Trinken noch
gibt.
Zum Beispiel fragt Diana: "Welche Souvenirs
gibt es auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt, die man nach
Russland schicken könnte?"
Habt ihr da einen Vorschlag?
Wir könnten mal ganz kurz hier rübergehen
und das angucken.
Warte mal, jetzt müssen wir uns ganz kurz
koordinieren, wir zeigen euch jetzt einige
Souvenirs.
Oh, Lorenz hat auch schon ausgetrunken.
Lorenz, du bist schnell.
Ich würde sagen, vielleicht kann Janusz mal
kurz rübergehen und ein paar Souvenirs zeigen,
du hast auch schon die Maske an.
Ja.
Und zwar geht es darum, Souvenirs zu zeigen,
die man hier kaufen kann.
Okay.
Also, hier stehen wir vor einem typischen
Souvenir-Stand und hier kann man ganz viele
niedliche, süße Figürchen kaufen.
Die kosten zehn Euro zum Beispiel, acht Euro,
die ganz kleinen kosten 3,50 Euro.
Und die kann man sich dann später irgendwo
zu Hause hinstellen und sich freuen.
Und…
Eine gute Beschreibung.
Und wir haben hier auch Sachen, die ich kaum
beschreiben kann und auch mir völlig unbekannt
sind, aber umso besser, umso interessanter
wird das.
Und wir können noch… Ich glaube, Cari will
jetzt übernehmen.
Will ich das?
Ja.
Okay.
Das mit den Kopfhörern ist immer so eine
Sache.
Ich zeige euch noch mal was, kommt mal mit
hier rüber.
Und zwar einmal hier, gibt es Rothenburger
Schneeballen, das ist so ein besonderes Gebäck.
Das haben wir schon mal vorgestellt vor zwei
Jahren, da waren wir mit Lisa und Maria in
Rothenburg.
Erinnerst du dich, Janusz?
Ja, klar, natürlich.
Ich habe diese(n) Geschmack immer noch im
Mund, so richtig… so süß, dass es dich
vom Hocker zieht.
Willst du dir einen einkaufen?
Nein, bitte nicht, ich…
Okay, jetzt nicht.
Dann gehen wir mal weiter.
Ich zeige euch noch was, und zwar…
Ich will eine Mütze anprobieren.
Janusz möchte eine Mütze anprobieren, das
können wir gleich auch zeigen.
Ich wollte euch mal das hier zeigen, das ist
so ein typischer Laden, wo es so Holzspielzeug
gibt und Holzdekoration.
Das ist ein gutes Geschenk, wenn man Geschenke
sucht für andere Länder, weil das ist wirklich
sehr typisch deutsch, das gibt es nicht in
allen Ländern.
Ich weiß aber nicht, ob man das gut nach
Russland schicken kann.
Muss man gut verpacken, ja.
Wir können mal weitergucken hier.
Aber du musst das noch erklären.
Also da kommt eine Kerze unten rein und dann,
dadurch, dass die Kerze Hitze macht, dreht
sich dann das Rad oben und unten dreht sich
das Karussell.
- Genau.
Mehrere Kerzen.
Genau.
- Hier unten kommen zum Beispiel vier Kerzen
und oben dreht sich das dann.
Ja.
Das ist wirklich cool, ich hab' das geliebt
als Kind.
- Kostet auch nur 190 Euro.
Wie viel?
190.
Wow.
Das ist… - Ja, ist ein bisschen viel.
…teuer, aber handgemacht wahrscheinlich.
Wollt ihr nicht reingehen?
Guck mal, Janusz, was haben wir denn hier?
Janusz, was ist das?
Das ist der… Ich habe das Wort vergessen.
Der Nussknacker.
Der Nussknacker, ja.
Was kann man mit dem Nussknacker machen?
Ein Märchen für Kinder, glaube ich, machen.
Und kann der nicht auch Nüsse knacken?
Normalerweise ja.
Okay.
Manuel, ich glaube, wir verlassen jetzt den
Weihnachtsmarkt.
Was hältst du davon?
Davon halte ich sehr viel.
Zeigt uns mal ein bisschen, wie der Alexanderplatz
sonst noch aussieht.
Wir müssen ja zumindest den Fernsehturm noch
mal zeigen.
Ja.
Und… - Das machen wir.
Ja, das war schön, dass wir mal einen Weihnachtsmarkt
gesehen haben.
Ich möchte noch mal zur Einordnung sagen,
dass der Weihnachtsmarkt am Alexanderplatz
nicht der schönste Weihnachtsmarkt Deutschlands
ist, also.
Oh, das Karussell geht los hier.
Oh.
Na, das ist ja… Also es gibt sehr viel schönere
Weihnachtsmärkte, sowohl in Berlin und gerade
auch so in kleineren Städten oder in Dörfern
in Deutschland.
Da gibt es manchmal so richtig schöne, traditionelle
Weihnachtsmärkte.
Da steht dann nicht so eine große Mülltonne
da rum und da gibt es dann wirklich handgemachte
Sachen und so Menschen, die wirklich Dinge
verkaufen, die sie selbst herstellen.
Also das ist dann noch etwas schöner und
traditioneller.
Eine Sekunde, Manuel.
Ich muss noch mal hier mit meinen Kopfhörern
rumhampeln.
Ja.
Lorenz kann uns ja mal den Platz ein bisschen
zeigen währenddessen.
Manuel, ich bin jetzt aus dem Weihnachtsmarkt
raus, ich konnte meine Maske abnehmen.
Und jetzt kann ich dir mal zeigen, wie es
hier außerhalb des Weihnachtsmarkts aussieht.
Wir sollen da vor die Uhr gehen und dann die
Weltuhr zeigen.
Wir zeigen euch gleich die schöne Uhr, aber
ansonsten.
Ich zeige mal ganz kurz, wie es hier aussieht.
Es ist grau, es ist eine Baustelle, es sind
große graue Gebäude.
Es ist sehr viel Platz, sehr viel Abstand.
Oh, und hier seht ihr die Polizeiwache, die
Wache am Alexanderplatz.
Die ist neu, oder?
Die gibt es seit ein paar Jahren, weil hier
gibt es leider auch, ja, wenn hier nachts
viele Menschen sind, braucht man auch die
Polizei.
Ja, was kann man zum Alexanderplatz noch sagen?
Vielleicht gehen wir mal ein bisschen weiter
da rüber, da fährt gerade die Tram mitten
durch den Platz hier durch, wie du siehst.
Die fährt extra langsam, damit…
Genau, hier ist nämlich nur Verkehr für
Fußgänger und für die Tram.
Es gibt keine Autos auf dem Alexanderplatz.
Richtig.
Und wie du siehst, geht dort der Weihnachtsmarkt
weiter und dort sieht er auch viel schöner
aus.
Dort gibt es Holzhütten, es gibt die Pyramide,
da steht auch der Pyramiden-Treff.
Also jetzt seht ihr doch noch mal, wie das
aussieht, und…
Paul merkt an: "Oh, nicht so schön, der Alex
ist ziemlich hässlich."
Das ist übrigens ein guter Punkt, die Berliner
nennen den Alexanderplatz "Alex", einfach
nur "Alex".
Wir sind auf dem Alex oder wir treffen uns
auf dem Alex.
Warte.
Janusz möchte jetzt die Uhr vorstellen.
Ich gebe mal, ich übergebe hier, Manuel,
ja?
Ja.
Das ist jetzt also die Weltzeituhr, ein beliebter
Treffpunkt auch für Berliner.
Ja, der allerdings eine gewisse Ironie nicht
entbehrt, weil die…
Ich mache mal deine Haare schön, Janusz.
Danke.
Weil die DDR-Regierung hat diese wunderschöne
Uhr ihrem Volk geschenkt sozusagen, weil das
Volk ja das Land nicht verlassen durfte.
Dann durfte er (es) sich dann eine Welttour
zumindest angucken.
Okay, interessant.
Das ist die Geschichte der Weltzeituhr.
Janusz, Dusan fragt, ob du heute schlecht
gelaunt bist oder kommt ihm das nur so vor?
Ich bin nicht schlecht gelaunt, aber ehrlich
gesagt, Alexanderplatz macht mich immer so
ein bisschen traurig, ich weiß nicht warum.
Und jemand anderes… - Man muss aber hier
einmal das Ganze gesehen haben.
Guck mal in die Kamera rein.
Ja.
Und MK wollte noch wissen oder hätte sich
noch gewünscht, dass du auf das Karussell
gehst.
Das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich…
Oh, schade, zu spät. - …zu spät.
Dabei hatte ich richtig Lust, da raufzusteigen,
ja.
Machen wir beim nächsten Mal.
Ja, machen wir beim nächsten Mal.
- Okay, wollt ihr mal in Richtung…
Ich übergebe an Cari wieder.
Jawoll.
Versuch, gute Laune zu verbreiten.
Die Leute beschweren sich, dass ich schlecht
gelaunt sind (bin).
Okay, Janusz ist schlecht gelaunt, kein Thema,
das ändern wir jetzt.
Ich habe total gute Laune, Manuel.
Was möchtest du als Nächstes von uns wissen?
Wollt ihr mal in Richtung Fernsehturm gehen,
dass wir den mal sehen?
- Das machen wir jetzt.
Jawoll.
Guck mal, wir zeigen einmal den ganzen Turm,
von hier sieht man den nämlich.
Der Alex…
Wir sind solche Idioten, wir haben die Gläser
nicht zurückgegeben.
Guck mal, Manuel, ich zeige dir jetzt noch
mal ein Phänomen hier.
Lorenz, zeig mal ganz kurz.
Janusz hat Pfandmarken bekommen, das müsst
ihr euch merken.
Wenn irgendwie auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt seid
oder irgendwo, wo man Gläser bekommt, kriegt
man Pfandmarken und da muss man die Gläser
mit den Pfandmarken…
Oh, du hörst gerade unseren Podcast?
Ja, ich… gerade ich bin… höre deinen
Podcast in (auf dem) Fahrrad und es ist unglaublich.
Das ist wirklich unglaublich.
Für mich ist… Du bist du wie ein Superstar
für mich, ja.
Ich bin drei Monate hier und ich kenne dich
für so lange, Leute.
Ich komme aus Chile, ich habe nur Deutsch
gelernt, weil… Podcast hören, weißt du?
Also for me…
Wir sind gerade auf YouTube, willst du mal
Hallo sagen?
- Schick ihm mal Grüße von mir und ein paar
hundert Zuschauern auf YouTube.
Live?
Jetzt?
Ja, live.
Oh!
Oh, hallo Leute!
Ich bin sehr froh, dass sie hier sind.
Manuel ist gerade mit uns verbunden, er schickt
dir Grüße.
Manuel, Grüße für dich auch.
Hallo.
Oh Leute, ich liebe dich alles (euch alle).
Danke, danke, danke.
Oh, wie schön!
Das freut uns total, dass du…
Es ist zwei Tage, dass du freu… ah no, it's
Freitag, Freitag.
Ja, die Party.
Freitag ist die Party, kommst du?
Ja, ich komme, ja, natürlich.
Ich bin Mitglied().
- Freitag ist unsere…
Ja.
Leute, macht (werdet) Mitglied(), du hast
alles hier, ja.
Vokabelhilfe, alles, ja.
Zeig mal die Vokabelhilfe, Cari.
- Wie heißt du?
- Sandino.
Ich heiße Sandino, ja.
Zeig mal, dass man das mal sieht.
Manuel fragt, ob du mal die Vokabelhilfe zeigen
kannst.
Von unserem Podcast.
Ein bisschen näher mit der Kamera.
Ich kann zeigen der (die) Vokabelhilfe, dann
du hast Notes.
Das ist sehr hilfreich für mich, ja.
Sehr hilfreich.
Ja, sehr hilfreich.
It's amazing, ja.
Es ist…
Du musst noch mal sagen, du bist gerade zufällig
vorbeigekommen.
Ich war… Ich ging zur deutsche(n) Bank,
genau, das ist da, und ja, ich komme in der
(mit dem) Fahrrad an, ich habe es gesehen.
Wunderbar.
Sandino, freut uns sehr, dich zu treffen.
Ja.
Ich liebe euch.
Ciao!
Das war doch abgesprochen, Cari.
Das war doch… - Nein, das war nicht abgesprochen.
Dann… Wir müssen das jetzt kurz erklären.
Also, was er gerade gezeigt hat, ist die Vokabelhilfe.
Die bekommt ihr unter anderem, wenn ihr ein
Mitglied von uns werdet auf Patreon, und dann
bekommt ihr zu unserem Podcast diese Vokabelhilfe
und ein interaktives Transkript.
Und die Weihnachtsfeier, von der er gerade
sprach, die findet in ein paar Tagen statt,
mit allen unseren Mitgliedern.
Das heißt, wenn ihr jetzt noch ein Mitglied
werdet von Easy German, wir blenden euch mal
hier den Link ein, wo das geht, dann könnt
ihr dieses Wochenende noch eine virtuelle
Weihnachtsfeier mit uns feiern.
Wir würden uns sehr freuen.
Dann feiert ihr mit uns online im Internet.
Manuel, ich möchte noch kurz zu Ende sagen,
das mit dem Pfand, ne?
Das ist so typisch in Deutschland.
Man bekommt eine Pfandmarke und die muss man
zurückgeben.
Wie viel Pfand hast du bezahlt?
Ich weiß es nicht, aber ziemlich viel, weil
ich habe für diese drei Getränke 20 Euro
bezahlt.
Was?
What?
Ja, und ich glaube, ich… Das ist wahrscheinlich
fünf Euro das Stück oder so.
Nee, wahrscheinlich kriegst du einen Euro
zurück mit dieser Pfandmarke für das Glas
und wir haben sie einfach stehen lassen.
Ja, ungünstig.
Manuel, ich möchte dir noch einen bekannten
Anblick zeigen vom Alexanderplatz, und zwar
ist das der Bahnhof Alexanderplatz.
Der ist also zwischen dem Platz und dem Turm,
ist einer der größten Bahnhöfe in Berlin.
Und dort fahren die S-Bahnen oben und unten
die U-Bahnen und auf der Straße die Tram.
Also drei verschiedene Verkehrsmittel treffen
sich hier, aus ganz Berlin kommen sie hier
zusammen.
Und wenn man in Berlin wohnt, dann muss man
hier ziemlich oft vorbei und kann hier umsteigen.
Oh, da kommt die Tram, die wird jetzt direkt
an uns vorbeifahren.
Ich zeige mal kurz, wie der Bahnhof früher
aussah, so um die Jahrhundertwende herum,
also 1904 ist dieses Bild, glaube ich, entstanden.
Damals gab es noch Kutschen, aber da gab es
auch schon die Tram und da sieht man diesen
Bahnhof.
Der wurde zwar im Krieg zerstört, hier sieht
man, wie der Alexanderplatz nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg aussah, also, sehr viel Zerstörung
natürlich durch den Krieg.
Und ja, mittlerweile ist natürlich alles
modernisiert und neu aufgebaut.
Manuel, ich ärgere mich jetzt gerade immer
noch über die Pfandmarken, die wir nicht
zurückgebracht haben.
Das ist…
Vielleicht könnt ihr die gleich verschenken
und jemand anderes, der die Gläser findet…
Man kann die ja nur mit den Gläsern zurückgeben
und die haben wir ja stehen lassen, ne?
Gut.
Ja.
Okay, so, jetzt verlasst ihr also den Alexanderplatz
und geht in Richtung Fernsehturm, der schon
offiziell nicht mehr auf dem Alexanderplatz
steht, sondern daneben.
Oh, hier ist es sehr laut hier, die Tram fährt
hier um die Ecke und es macht sehr viel Krach.
Ja, wir gehen jetzt zum Fernsehturm.
Was findet man hier auf dem Weg?
Typische Geschäfte am Alexanderplatz, Döner
und Pizza, Fish & Chips.
Es gibt sehr viel zu essen hier, sehr viel
touristische Orte, würde ich mal sagen, und
es ist sehr laut.
Guck, da kommt schon die nächste Tram, die
total viel Krach macht.
Ja, es ist ein echter Umschlagplatz, ne?
Also, man steigt um von U-Bahn zu Tram.
Genau, es ist vor allem eigentlich ein großer
Bahnhof, auf dem man hin und her geht.
So, und wir gehen jetzt gleich rüber zu dem
Turm, der ist jetzt allerdings auf der anderen
Seite von hier.
Da müssen wir erst mal warten, bis die Tram
weggefahren ist.
Janusz, bist du noch da?
Wie geht es dir, Janusz?
Wie fühlst du dich…
Ja, mir geht es sehr gut.
Wie fühlst du dich am Alexanderplatz?
Ja, wie immer, grimmig.
Janusz fühlt sich heute gut, aber er zeigt
es nicht so.
Ach, doch, es ist auch schön mit euch.
Schön.
Ja, soll ich euch noch ein paar Fragen…
- Irgendwann gehen wir da nach oben und zeigen
euch den Ausblick von Berlin von oben.
Leider können wir jetzt gerade nicht hochfahren,
aber wir sind jetzt fast da.
Lorenz, du kannst mal zeigen, wenn hier die
ganzen Trams vorbeifahren, dann geht es hier
hoch zum Fernsehturm.
Und was hast du über den Fernsehturm zu erzählen,
Janusz?
Ja, ratet mal, wie groß der ist.
Es wurde quasi noch von der DDR-Regierung
gebaut und sie waren natürlich mächtig stolz
dadrauf, aber als die Sonne angefangen hat
zu scheinen, ist der Abglanz von der Sonne
in der Kugel, also der Abglanz der Sonne in
der Kugel ergibt ein Kreuz.
Und darüber lachten natürlich alle, weil
ja die DDR-Regierung strikt antikatholisch
oder antireligiös war, und dann haben sie
sich selber so ein Eigentor geschossen ein
bisschen.
Also in der Kugel von dem Turm spiegelt sich
ein Kreuz, das aussieht wie ein christliches
Kreuz.
Und das war nicht die Intention der Regierung,
sondern ein Zufall, ein Architektur-Zufall.
Manuel hat eine Frage für uns, und zwar sollen
wir raten, wie hoch der Turm ist.
357 Meter.
Ich bin total schlecht darin, so was zu raten,
ehrlich gesagt.
Also die Gebäude, die hier drum herum stehen,
die sind vielleicht… Ich habe gar keine
Ahnung, 30 Meter hoch?
Ich schätze mal 200 Meter, Manuel.
Also, Janusz lag, ich kann es kaum glauben,
nur elf Meter daneben.
368 Meter.
- Janusz war nur elf Meter daneben.
Und er ist damit…
Dabei habe ich es mir wirklich aus dem Finger
herausgesagt.
Du hast es dir aus den Fingern gezogen.
Gezogen, ja.
Das heißt, du wusstest gar nichts.
Absolut nicht, war so ein Lotterie-Raten.
Ja, Glückwunsch, Janusz.
Danke sehr.
Und es ist damit der, das höchste Gebäude
in Deutschland und immerhin der vierthöchste
Fernsehturm in Europa.
Früher war einmal… - Das ist das höchste
Gebäude in Deutschland, Manuel?
Das ist das höchste Gebäude in Deutschland,
aber da ist ja oben noch so eine ganz hohe
Antenne drauf, die den natürlich noch mal
sehr viel höher macht als da, wo die Kugel
ist.
Aber der Fernsehturm…
Janusz, wusstest du das?
Das ist das höchste Gebäude in Deutschland.
Ja, wusste ich.
Okay, ich nicht.
Aber den Fernsehturm kann man wirklich überall
sehen, wenn man in Berlin unterwegs ist, den
Fernsehturm sieht man so gut (wie) von jeder
Ecke, hat man das Gefühl, finde ich.
Vor allem in Ost-Berlin sieht man den tatsächlich,
sind die Straßen teilweise so… Also der
ist so gebaut worden, die Straßen waren meistens
vorher schon da, aber der Turm steht so, dass
man den in jeder Straße fast sieht.
Und das ist schon bemerkenswert, also, wenn
man bei uns zum Beispiel die Straße runtergeht,
und wir wohnen schon einige Kilometer weg
von dem Turm, sieht man den immer noch.
Ja.
Ja, so, ich wollte noch mal hier Grüße schicken,
der Kommentar ist schon vorbei, aber tatsächlich
kam gerade ein Kommentar von Kelli, die in
der Tram saß, die gerade vorbeigefahren ist.
Nein, wirklich?
Ja, liebe Grüße.
- Jemand schreibt uns Grüße aus der Tram,
die gerade bei uns vorbeigefahren ist.
Und ja, ich glaube, wir müssen auch bald
schon zum Ende kommen.
Was wollt ihr uns denn zum Abschluss noch
zeigen?
Vielleicht können wir dir noch die Verkehrsregeln
hier zeigen auf dem Alexanderplatz.
Mal sehen, was wir hier… - Hier ist noch
mal der Kommentar von Kelli.
In Deutschland gibt es ja einige Regeln.
Das hier ist offensichtlich eine geschützte
Grünanlage.
Dafür, dass das hier eine Grünanlage gibt…
ist, gibt es hier sehr wenig Grün, vielleicht
kannst du noch mal rumschwenken, Lorenz.
Man sieht, es gibt ein paar Bäume, die haben
jetzt keine Blätter mehr.
Das ist also hier in Berlin eine geschützte
Grünanlage.
Dahinten, diese Kübel mit grün.
Außerdem ist hier: Hunde sind anzuleinen,
Fußballspielen ist verboten.
Und was heißt das?
Ich glaube, das ist erlaubt, deshalb ist es
grün.
Es heißt, es ist…
Spielen und Fahrradfahren ist in Ordnung,
genau.
…mit Vorsicht zu genießen.
Radfahren ist auf befestigten Wegen erlaubt,
Fußgänger haben aber Vorrang.
Das heißt, wenn der Fußgänger kommt, muss
der zuerst durch.
Der Verzehr von Alkohol und das Rauchen sind
verboten, Zuwiderhandlungen werden geahndet.
Kein Alkohol auf dem Alexanderplatz.
Das ist…
Da muss ich nur lachen, weil wir haben ja
gesehen.
Wir haben ja selber gerade Alkohol getrunken.
Ja.
Früher war der Alexanderplatz auch sehr beliebt
bei Skateboardern.
Also in der DDR-Zeit, da, die ersten Skater
in Deutschland, die haben da viel auf diesem
Platz unter dem Turm… also, eigentlich nicht
der Alexanderplatz, sondern da direkt unter
dem Turm, da wurde früher viel geskatet.
Wir sind ja direkt unter dem Turm, vielleicht
kann Lorenz das noch mal zeigen, wie nah wir
jetzt am Turm dran sind.
Direkt hier vorne ist der Turm und von hier
geht es also ganz nach oben in den höchst…
der höchste Turm Deutschlands.
Ich habe es wirklich nicht gewusst, ich bin
überrascht.
Und sagt mal, Norman möchte wissen, ob der
noch benutzt wird, um das Fernsehsignal wirklich
zu übertragen.
Oder ist das heute nicht mehr so?
Das wäre gut, wenn ich das wüsste.
Ich weiß es aber nicht.
Oh!
Hallo.
Ich weiß es leider auch nicht, keine Ahnung.
Ja, das kann ich dir leider nicht sagen.
Ja, Manuel, weiß ich nicht.
Wie fandest du jetzt diesen Rundgang hier
am Alexanderplatz?
Sehr schön, ich sehe es so ein bisschen so
wie Janusz.
Also der Alexanderplatz ist nicht der schönste
Ort in Berlin, aber es ist ein wichtiger Ort.
Man ist als Berliner ab und zu da, wenn man
umsteigt, als Tourist kommt man dahin, um
auf den Turm zu gehen.
Ich glaube, der Fernsehturm, da hochzufahren
mit dem Aufzug kostet 15 Euro oder so, deswegen
ist das jetzt nicht was, was man häufig macht.
Aber das werden wir machen, ich habe mir schon
ein Architektur-Guide-Buch gekauft, um imstande
zu sein, die Gebäude, die wir dann sehen
von oben aus, ein bisschen zu beschreiben.
Ich möchte allerdings euch noch mal einen
Tipp geben: Wenn ihr nach Berlin kommt, vielleicht
kann Lorenz das einmal zeigen, dann würde
ich nicht auf den Turm fahren, sondern auf
das Park Inn, das hat auch ein Panoramadeck
oben.
Und von dort aus hat man nämlich auch einen
guten Überblick über Berlin, plus man sieht
noch den Turm dazu.
Und das ist ein sehr schöner Überblick über
die Stadt.
Was für ein Gewinn, Leute.
Ja, schön ihr beiden.
Manuel, haben wir den Alexanderplatz gut repräsentiert,
mit all seinen Schönheiten?
Ihr habt ihn perfekt repräsentiert und gezeigt.
Und ich würde sagen, schön, dass ihr alle
dabei wart.
Was sagt man am Ende von so einem Livestream?
Abonnieren nicht vergessen.
Abonnieren.
Klickt die Glocke, es bimmelt dann bei euch.
Und meldet euch gerne an als Mitglied von
Easy German.
Das wäre für uns das schönste Weihnachtsgeschenk.
Damit unterstützt ihr unsere Arbeit und ihr
seid bei der Weihnachtsfeier dabei am Wochenende.
Genau, da freue ich mich drauf und ja.
Da freue ich mich aber auch.
Das ist am Freitag, ne?
Genau.
Am Freitag sehen wir euch, viele von euch
zu unserer Weihnachtsfeier.
Ich freue mich schon dadrauf.
Bis bald, kommt gut nach Hause!
- Bis bald.
Tschüss!
- Ciao!